[President Franklin D. Roosevelt dedicates
the National Institute of Health]
Robert Trout: The President of the United
States dedicates the National Institute of
Health in Bethesda, Maryland.
Six hours ago, the Presidential special train
rolled into Washington's Union Station, bringing
the President back from his one-day New England
tour, which ended in Boston last night.
[Bethesda, Maryland, October 31, 1940]
And now the President has come by automobile
to the National Health Institute in Bethesda,
Maryland, on the outskirts of Washington.
Here on a pleasant Indian summer afternoon,
a moderate sized audience has gathered before
the white column, red brick administration
building set in the green, rolling Maryland
hills, and surrounded by trees thick with
red and yellow autumn leaves.
[Speaking: Robert Trout, CBS News]
Announcer: Ladies and gentlemen, the President
of the United States.
[Applause]
President Roosevelt: Mr. Coy, Dr. Thompson,
the Governor of Maryland, Governor O'Connor,
ladies and gentlemen.
Nowhere in the world, except in the Americas
is it possible for any nation to devotee great
sector of its effort to life conservation
rather than life destruction.
All of us are grateful that we in the United
States can still turn our thoughts and our
attention to those institutions of our country
that symbolize peace.
Institutions whose purpose it is to save life,
and not to destroy it.
It is for the dedication of these noble buildings
to the service of man that we are assembled
here today.
The National Institute of Health speaks the
universal language of humanitarianism.
It has been devoted throughout its long, distinguished
history, to furthering the health of all mankind,
in which service, it has recognized no limitations
imposed by international boundaries, and has
recognized no distinctions of race or creed
or of color.
The total defense that we have heard so much
about of late, that total defense which this
nation seeks, involves a great deal more than
building airplanes and ships and guns and
bombs.
For we cannot be a strong nation unless we
are a healthy nation.
So we must recruit not only men and materials,
but also knowledge and science to service
our national strength, and that is what we
are doing here.
We have recognized the strategic importance
of health by the creation of a Health and
Medical Committee in the Council of National
Defense itself.
That committee has the job of coordinating
the health and medical aspects of national
preparedness.
That Committee is assisting the government
in the mobilization of the medical and health
resources of the country to serve the best
interests both of the military and the civilian
elements of the nation.
To do this will require the best energies
of professional and technical leadership everywhere
in the United States.
To do this will require the fullest cooperation
between the government and the hospitals,
the medical, the dental, the nursing, and
other professions.
We seek the same partnership that we seek
for industrial production in the Advisory
Committee.
Neither the American people nor their government
intend to socialize medical practice any more
than they plan to socialize industry.
In American life, the family doctor, the general
practitioner performs a service which we rely
upon and which we trust as a nation.
No one has a greater appreciation than I of
the skill and self-sacrifice of the medical
profession.
And there can be no substitute for the personal
relationship between doctor and patient, which
is a characteristic and a source of strength
of medical practice in our land.
Although we have a great deal to do, the nation
today, I'm very certain, is better prepared
to meet the public health programs of our
emergency than at any previous time in the
history of the country.
Since the passage of the famous Social Security
Act, with its health provisions, in 1935,
federal, state, and local health and medicine
are cooperating more broadly than ever before.
Our people are better informed on health matters
than ever before.
Scientific knowledge of the causes of disease,
and also the conditions for health has exceeded
any previous limits.
Facilities for health and medical service
are more numerous and they're better.
The Public Health Service of the United States
is a very old institution and it's done magnificent
work, but it has only recently, in the past
few years that the federal government has
indicated that it can do infinitely more...
that disease disregards state lines as well
as national lines.
That among these states there is, as we know,
an inequality of opportunity for health.
In such cases, the Public Health Service is
helping and must continue, even more greatly,
to help.
That partnership, and I emphasize that word,
in regard to health and medicine throughout
the land, that partnership is making definite
progress among many diseases.
Among the buildings of the National Institute
of Health to be dedicated here today, stands
the National Cancer Institute, created through
provisions of the act which I signed on August
5, 1937.
The work of this new institute swell underway.
It is promoting and stimulating cancer research
throughout the nation.
It is bringing to the people of the nation
a message of hope, because many forms of the
disease are not only curable, but even preventable.
Beyond this it is doing research here and
in many universities to unravel the mysteries
of cancer.
I think we can all have faith in the ultimate
results of these great efforts.
These buildings that we dedicate represent
new and improved housing for an institution
that has a long and accomplished background
of accomplishment in this task of research.
The original demonstration of the cause and
method of preventing pellagra, for example,
has been followed by other important contributions.
Great work has been done in the control of
tularemia, Rocky Mountain Spotted Fever, typhus
fever, yellow fever, malaria, and sinacotis
[?].
Now that we are less than a day by plane from
the jungle-type yellow fever of South America,
less than two days from the sleeping sickness
of equatorial Africa, less than three days
from cholera and bubonic plague, the ramparts
we watch must be civilian in addition to being
military.
[Applause]
For the very beautiful and very spacious grounds
on which these buildings stand, we are indebted
to Mr. and Mrs. Luke Wilson, who wrote to
me in 1935, asking if a part of their estate
in Bethesda, in Maryland, could be used to
the benefit of the people of this nation.
I would tell her now, as she sits beside me,
that in the capacity, the compassion of Mr.
and Mrs. Wilson for suffering, in their hope
for human action to alleviate it, she and
her husband symbolize the aspirations of millions
of Americans for a cause such as this, and
we are very grateful.
[Applause]
Today, the need for the conservation of health
and physical fitness is greater than at any
time in this nation's history.
In dedicating this institute, I dedicate it
to the underlying philosophy of public health,
to the conservation of life, to the wise use
of the vital resources of the nation.
I voice, for America and for the stricken
world, our hopes, our prayers, our faith in
the power of man's humanity to man.
Robert Trout: The President of the United
States has dedicated the National Institute
of Health, a collection of six buildings set
in the sloping hills of Bethesda, Maryland,
a few miles from Washington.
[Music]
The
President spoke in this pleasant rural setting
in Bethesda, Maryland near Washington D.C.
this afternoon after a quick automobile drive
from Washington D.C., the capital city, in
which he arrived a few minutes after ten o'clock
this morning.
And now the small audience which has come
out to watch the President dedicate this National
Institute of Health is now moving away and
the President will soon motor back to the
White House in Washington.
This is Bob Trout speaking, this is the Columbia
Broadcasting System.
[President Franklin D. Roosevelt dedicates
the National Institute of Health]
[Produced by Audiovisual Program Development
Branch, Lister Hill National Center for Biomedical
Communications National Library of Medicine]
[Historic Photographs courtesy Franklin D.
Roosevelt Library, National Archives, Prints
and Photographs Collection, History of Medicine
Division, National Library of Medicine, Visitor
Information Center, National Institutes of
Health]
[Roosevelt Speech Audio courtesy National
Archives, WTOP Radio]
[National Library of Medicine Bethesda, Maryland
20894, 1991]